today the Matt Walsh show a woman tells
her detransition story and has
ruthlessly mocked ridiculed and
condemned by trans activists for it this
is the reality that people who regret
their transitions face also Kanye West
is no longer allowed to bank with JP
Morgan Chase meanwhile the same bank
kept its relationship with Jeffrey
Epstein for 15 years also what happened
to New York City mayor Eric Adams and
his campaign pledges to be tough on
crime whatever happened with that plus a
polyamorous Union is granted legal
recognition and in our daily
cancellation National Coming Out day
came and went this week with many people
clamoring to be included in the LGBT
Club because that's what you do with a
victim group right you want to be part
of it we'll talk about all that and more
today on the Matt Walsh show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
you know in my line of work I end up
spending a lot of time on my phone
preparing for the show answering emails
and uh well I don't really answer emails
at all but preparing for the show anyway
and of course trolling blue check marks
on Twitter it's my life calling
but what's scary is my phone carrier and
yours too collects data on whatever it
is I'm doing online mainstream phone
companies like Verizon or even admitting
to tracking your data so they can better
understand your interests as they put it
when really all they want to do is sell
your activity to advertisers the more
they can get on you the larger their
paycheck which is why I use expressvpn
expressvpn is an app that prevents your
phone carrier from being able to see the
sites you visit and sell it off to third
parties all it takes is one tap of the
button and all of your network data gets
encrypted and rerouted through
expressvpn's secure servers for ultimate
privacy not only does it Shield your web
browsing
expressvpn protects all of your network
data so you can stay private even when
using your favorite apps when your phone
carrier tracks you that's a grossian
gross invasion of privacy you can either
keep letting them cash in on you or you
can visit expressvpn.com Walsh to get
the same VPN that I use and Trust take
back your online privacy today and use
my link to get three extra months free
that's exp
resvpn.com Welsh
expressvpn.com Welsh
well you've perhaps seen this video
circulating over the past several days
it's not unlike the sorts of videos
we've seen with increasing and tragic
regularity recently in this case it's a
girl named Casey Miller who's now 21
years old began the process of gender
transition when she was 16 years old so
she now like so many others before her
and so many millions more to come after
her deeply regrets what was done to her
and I will not say that she regrets what
she did because this is not something
that she did she didn't decide to
uh aggressively indoctrinate herself
into a cult when she was at an
impressionable young age she didn't
choose to live in a society that's lost
its grip on reality all of that was
inflicted on her she is a victim and now
here she is
yeah
um so I got out of my haircut
um because my hair was driving me nuts
and I shaved it because I'm tired of
watching my hair thin out and it's less
distressing if I shave it so when I talk
about being too far gone not I don't
really know what else to call it
um this is what I mean this is how deep
my voice is
um it's gotten deeper over time and it's
settled
um this is what I mean by hair loss and
it just keeps getting worse it keeps
thinning it keeps receding backwards
um
you know and I'm not exactly sure that's
coming back
um those are the main things when I talk
about being androgenized
um to a point of no return
um I really don't see those being
fixable
so that's when I talk about you know
just kind of staying how I am regardless
of how I feel
um that's why just because I I don't
really see me personally being able to
come back from what's happened so far so
I hope that's a little explanatory
um just to kind of give a little bit
more of a
um like kind of the let me reward that
just to kind of you know
talk about like give more awareness to
the situation
um
kind of so you can see where I'm at
words are not working well with me right
now I'm just gonna cut this off
there you go
you know this this is what happens when
you give a woman testosterone this for
five years this is what happens
essentially so
you know that's it stay safe
so that's the reality that she is uh
trapped in and although she can live a
meaningful life obviously in a
fulfilling life the truth is that much
of what was done to her cannot be
reversed and she was convinced that 16
that she wanted something and
now she has to live with what the 16
year old version of herself thought she
wanted forever
as we can see in the video she's losing
her hair she has a receding hairline at
the age of 21.
a very common side effect of hormone
treatment for gender confused girls you
have to remember that girls are are um
not meant to have these levels of
testosterone in their systems their
bodies are not built for that the result
is oftentimes rapid hair loss not to
mention in many cases uh you know weight
gain acne those those are and those are
only the the relatively surface level
problems
but even the seemingly cosmetic side
effects are important because girls who
transition
all of them
are trying to turn themselves into
something that is obviously a fantasy
it's not real so they can never actually
be males they have some they have some
kind of vision of the kind of
man the kind of male they think they can
become
but that vision isn't real and it will
never be real
the same goes in the reverse for boys
who try to transition in the other
direction these girls because they're
confused and they've been brainwashed
and indoctrinated
they believe that in some ineffable
mysterious way
their fundamental Essence is that of a
man they're uh you know a boy trapped in
a girl's body as it's often expressed
and yet none of them imagine that this
boy trapped inside them is is overweight
with a receding hairline or chronic acne
and I don't say that obviously to make a
joke out of it at all there's nothing
remotely funny about this my point is
that is that is that every single gender
confused person male or female
is grasping for some Vision some fantasy
of themselves that isn't real and will
never be real
the girl rejects her femaleness in favor
of her fantasy of maleness but she'll
never achieve it she'll never she'll
never arrive at her destination she'll
be stuck instead in some sort of
hellish limbo having lost her femininity
but not having replaced it with anything
like masculinity
certainly not the sort of masculinity
that she had imagined in her head
she'll be stuck with some of the worst
aspects of of being a male you know
thinning hair for example
but she's not going to actually be a
male
one of the cruelest ironies is that a
transition the quote unquote female
will forever sound something like an
adolescent boy going through puberty but
we'll have the thinning hair and and
sometimes the beer gut of a 40 year old
and yet still will not look like an
adolescent boy or a 40 Old Man
this is what's being sold to teenage
girls
it's a ticket to the worst of all
possible worlds that's what's being sold
to them only they're not being told that
that's what's being sold to them
they're being sold on the surface of
fantasy and then this is what they get
but there's another aspect to the story
that hasn't gotten as much attention
uh the girl
who changes her mind
will not only be stuck with the
irreversible changes inflicted on her
body but to add vicious insult to severe
injury
she will also have to endure the
venomous attacks from trans activists
who will treat her like a traitor
if she decides that she'd rather Embrace
her biological identity than continue
living a lie
so the the comments under Casey's video
and Twitter are overrun
with trans people ruthlessly insulting
and mocking her ruthless
this includes prominent trans activists
with large followings who have sent
their Legions to tear this girl to
shreds
she's already suffering
she's already in a very dark place
obviously
and they're trying to send it right over
the edge
this is someone suffering and their
response is to mock her and belittle her
and express contempt for her
not only that but most of them are still
referring to her as him you know so much
for preferred pronouns they've decided
that she's a man and can never not be a
man no matter what she says about
herself
now I would go through and read you
examples of the sorts of things they're
saying but I think that would be that
would not be very productive and I also
don't really want to amplify these
insults though you can go to her page
and see it for yourself
so this is something to keep in mind
when when you and this is why it's
important because when you hear about
uh the the number of D transitioners and
people who are expressing regret about
their transitions
these are only the people willing to
speak out
in spite of the mockery and threats and
alienation and social ostracization
they'll experience because of it how
many more would be going public if not
for their fear of experiencing the exact
same kind of treatment
and also remember this when you hear the
claim that younger children are only
socially transitioning and that the
social transition uh it's not as serious
as a medical transition
when you hear that claim keep this in
mind oh we only socially transition
five-year-olds they say it's not like
we're performing surgery on them
yes we'll we'll see how long that lasts
because that's they they would like to
go to a point get to a point where
they're performing surgery on
five-year-olds
but regardless the social transition
leads inexorably and inevitably to the
medical transition because once the
child has started down this path it
becomes quickly clear to him that there
will be a severe social penalty for
changing course
so for all the talk of affirmation and
acceptance among left-wing trans
activists it's no surprise that these
are without question the least affirming
and accepting human beings on the face
of the planet
why is that
well simply because they care for
nothing and no one but themselves I mean
they they talk of affirmation but they
don't mean it in a you as a universal
principle
they don't care about you being affirmed
I don't give a damn about you you can go
to hell you can die
the way they're treating this girl as
far as exercise she can die she can kill
herself I mean some of them are very
very open about that they they her vow
her life does not matter to them she is
dirt she's scum she's a traitor as far
as they see it
the only sort of affirmation that they
care about or demand
is affirmation of themselves and of
their own life choices that's it it's
all about them individually
as they see it the entire human race
exists purely for this purpose to affirm
them and make them feel better and
nobody has any other purpose on Earth
but that which is why if you don't do
that if you don't affirm then you then
you can die too your life has no meaning
because your only purpose in life is to
affirm them personally it's the only
reason you're here
a d-trans person then is is the greatest
affront of all
because she makes the trans activists
feel bad about his choices
She lays bare the truth behind all the
lies that he tells himself and the world
her decision her life path is a is a
direct attack on him
as he perceives it
because he sees everything as directly
relating to him he cannot conceive of
realities that exist apart from him or
of a universe in which he is not the
center
hyper narcissism is the engine that
drives the trans movement and and
everything else on the left
it's no surprise then to see this
reaction also one of the undying truths
of life and it's a cliche but it's true
is that misery loves company
the trans activist is miserable and
unhappy
and he lashes out at anyone who tries to
escape the prison that he has put
himself into
you you are not allowed to leave this
behind and strive for a a more whole and
complete Life One lived in harmony with
your biological nature rather than at
war with it you're not allowed to do
that because he's not doing that
and he wants you to remain trapped
and in despair
same as him
but that also goes back to the
narcissism
and that's what lies at the core
of all of this
now let's get to our five headlines
a couple of notes uh that I I think it's
relevant to bring them now first of all
we are I guess sort of at the the end of
our first leg of our uh what is a woman
College Tour and University of Houston
will be tonight we're in Houston right
now and
um uh it's been uh it's just been
extraordinary so far everywhere we've
won we went through this will be our
fourth place and every College we've
gone to have been uh they've been sold
out crowds jam-packed rooms and
auditoriums I mean we're filling
auditoriums to capacity and beyond that
turning people away because we can't fit
everybody in uh and and uh and the
protesters are showing up too you know
protest and they're planning on a big
protest tonight we'll see if it
materializes or not but
uh it doesn't matter because they are
vastly outnumbered by everybody else
and this is
again college campus tour
and we're talking about gender ideology
and it's it's well known that I am a I
am a strident critic of it
and they're packing the room
I think what that tells us is that
college students
not all of them anyway are um ours have
bought into gender ideology quite to the
extent that we're being told
so there is hope yet
and uh and also as we kind of wrap this
up and we'll be we'll be heading back
out on the road to do more colleges in a
couple of weeks but before that we're
going back to Nashville and on October
21st that's uh next Friday outside the
state capitol in Nashville we're gonna
have our rallies and child mutilation
expecting a big crowd there as well and
uh just to remind you that
you know we had a major victory with
Vanderbilt but that that's that's just
the beginning
um that by no means
uh translates into hey we can just pack
our bags and go home and wipe our hands
of it and say hey we we want we can't do
that the Fight Continues and it'll
continue on Fridays we hope to see you
there next Friday October 21st all right
so checking in to begin with with the
crime problem in New York where violent
crime murder property crime all kinds of
crime are continuing to Skyrocket not
hard to understand why here's uh Fox
News quote a 31 year old New York City
man who was arrested and released
without bail last month after
terrorizing McDonald's patrons with an
ax
was arrested again this week for
graffiti stealing a bike and evading
police
and was again released without bail
Michael Palacios Palacios was approached
by police Sunday evening after being
spotted spraying graffiti in Brooklyn
prompting him to snatch an expensive
bike from nearby coffee shop and Lead
officers on a chase before eventually
being arrested the bike valued at 3 500
was damaged during the chase New York
City the New York Police Department
confirmed the Fox News digital the
department says that the criminal here
was found in possession of graffiti
paraphernalia and Authority suspect he's
also responsible for another graffiti
incident in Queens in June he was
charged with grand larceny two counts of
criminal mischief possession of stolen
property making graffiti and possession
of graffiti instrument he was also
charged for the graffiti incident in
June
and but he was released right away so
you may remember this guy he's the guy
from the video that was circulating a
few weeks ago where he was uh running
around McDonald's with an ax
smashing things and terrorizing
customers that's something you can do in
New York now just pull an ax out and
start wielding it in the middle of a
fast food restaurant
he was arrested for that and immediately
released
and then he goes out and commits more
crimes and he's arrested for those and
immediately erased released
Democrats are doing literally everything
they can to create as much crime as they
possibly can they're going out of their
way
while also going to increasingly
desperate lengths to deny that this
surge is happening so CNN contributor
Errol Louise
tweeted a short video yesterday with
this caption here's the caption
going home on the Violent New York City
Subways Riders paralyzed with fright
this is all sarcastic of course because
then in the video you can see people
standing around and uh everything is
fine
so he's met he's making a mockery of
people that are complaining about crime
in New York City this is their counter
argument okay this is what counts as a
counter argument for them it's uh oh
yeah well look at this section of the
subway where for these 10 seconds
nobody's being stabbed
you see crime is a myth
you claim there's a crime problem but
but see look at these four people who
are not currently being murdered
got you now
this is what this is uh this qualifies
as a rebuttal on the left
and I'm here's what's gonna happen this
video will be used by fact checking
sites if you claim on Twitter now that
the crime is on the rise in New York
they will they're going to label it
false or they're going to say false
missing context and then you click on
the link and it's going to send you to
this video
which proves that you know because it
proves yeah you say crime is uh on the
rise but but this video proves that
there are at least some occasions where
in some parts of the city there are no
crimes visibly in progress
which means that crime isn't a problem
at all
these tactics are just a kind of
political masturbation for Democrats
though that's really it is because it
satisfies them and makes them feel
better
but it doesn't fool anybody else
people who live in these communities
they know the truth
and and Democrats will suffer
politically because of it
I agree with Ann Coulter wrote a piece
about this yesterday she says and I
agree with her that she says that if if
Eric Adams in New York the New York city
mayor
if he had actually made good on his
promise to cut crime if he'd actually
been tough on crime as he promised uh
that's the way that he was elected
he was even getting credit and props
from the right because the way that he
was talking about the crime problem
he was talking about it as though it is
a problem
which is groundbreaking on the left well
you're oh you're willing to admit that
violent crime is a problem and shouldn't
happen and that step should be taken to
prevent it wow
that's revolutionary you don't hear this
from Democrats
so that's what he said and uh but then
he he gets in there and
doesn't do anything about it if he had
if he had actually been tough on crime
as he promised he would prob he would
walk into the White House in 2024 I
think a black mayor of New York who's
charismatic he is charismatic and
demonstrates actual real concern
for the problems in his community and is
willing to do what needs to be done to
solve them
and is not a full-on far left lunatic
but is only slightly
it is only a slight lunatic not a far
not not a full-on lunatic uh he'd be a
formidable political force I think
but he's a Democrat and that precludes
him from trying to solve real problems
they're just they're not allowed to try
to solve real problems
one other thing I'll say about this is
that I struggle to do
um what a lot of people on the right do
with these these this these stories now
about crime in the big cities and
a lot of conservatives will say well
these people voted for it
um let them have it this is what they
wanted you're getting what you wanted
not my problem I don't care I'm not
going to talk about it
I understand that attitude and it is
true that the voters are voting for this
this is what they're voting for
and every time I knew another election
comes up they have a chance it's not
like there aren't uh
there aren't other options they have a
chance to vote for someone who might
actually
try to prevent crime and punish it and
they choose not to
so I get that and and I understand it
and uh that makes sense
but I have trouble accepting that answer
and the reason simply is that uh I don't
want the criminals to win
yeah the voters in these cities they are
getting what they want
in New York City
despite what this CNN contributor might
be claiming
it's just doing your normal uh morning
commute is a danger now you have to
worry about that you're on the subway
you got to worry about some crazed
lunatic running around along and just
like throwing you onto the subway tracks
or assaulting you randomly or killing
you for no reason I mean these are the
things you got to worry about
and uh but you voted for it
and so it's hard for me to have a lot of
sympathy and yet
you know my desire for these crimes to
be punished is less it's not rooted so
much in Sympathy for the idiots who vote
for it but it's rooted in uh like we
talked about yesterday a desire for
justice
and I don't want these criminals to win
I want them to be punished because uh
because they they need to be
and as I said if they are punished that
would help the Democrats if these
Democrat Mayors started punishing crime
it would help them politically
I want it to happen because I want these
criminals to be punished that's what
they deserve it's Justice
and I cannot simply just accept
Injustice
you have to accept it because it exists
in the world you can't stop it but but
uh but I I
I still desire for it to be for it to be
writed okay um this from the daily wire
JPMorgan Chase said in a statement
obtained by the daily wire on Wednesday
that it has ended its banking
relationship with rapper Kanye West's
business
the statement which was scant on details
was obtained by Candace Owens on the
same day that Owens launched her new
documentary in the daily wire the
greatest lie ever sold which is being
very well received by by the audience
and they said the bank said in an email
to Wes quote we are sending this letter
to confirm our recent discussion with
and then it's redacted
that JPMorgan Chase Bank has decided to
end its banking relationship with Yeezy
LLC
to provide the company with sufficient
time to transition to another financial
institution we will continue to maintain
the accounts
uh until November 21st 2022. now the
statement goes on but they don't really
explain why they're doing this
and but we can
we can assume you know there might be
more to this maybe there's more
information will come out but we've seen
this kind of thing before we've heard
this song before and it cannot be a
coincidence that they're making this
announcement at right at the time during
the week during this new cycle when
Kanye West is being criticized for the
things that he's saying and and now
that's when they come along and they say
well we're ending our banking
relationship with you
we've seen this before this is this is
what they do all you need to know
about this
is that JPMorgan Chase
okay they're ending their business with
Kanye West
seemingly because he has said
controversial things
and yet JP Morgan Chase kept doing
business with Jeffrey Epstein for 15
years
they kept him as a client
okay for I'm looking this up right now
yeah for 15 years
and that means they kept them as a
client for five years after he was
charged with sex crimes against children
they knew what this guy was all about
and they kept them on board
in fact this was a story that came out a
little while ago that they there were
internal messages going back and forth
where they people within the banking uh
within JP Morgan Chase were
acknowledging who this guy was they know
what he's about and they decided to keep
him anyway why did they keep him well
because first of all lots of wealthy
bankers
were themselves clients of Epstein
and also because these decisions are not
based on any sort of ethical standard
that's not what this is about
and what they're doing here to Kanye
West it is it is stage setting
and you might think
and maybe you take some comfort in
saying well this is Kanye West uh also
he said stuff that I don't say and so I
don't got to worry about it
uh that's it that is a that is a false
reassurance that you're giving yourself
because the other way of looking at it
so I think it's a more accurate way
it's not that oh well they would only do
this to Kanye not me it's that if
they'll do that to Kanye West
of course they'll do it to you
he's world famous he's got lots of money
JP Morgan Chase is making lots of money
off of him and his company
they've got millions of dollars at stake
here also and they're going to give that
up
for ideological reasons and political
reasons
so if they would do that to him of
course they would do it to you or to me
and it's uh so and and that's where you
start you start with somebody like Kanye
West who although he's a mainstream
world famous figure
um some of his statements and ideas are
Fringe and so in a certain sense you're
kind of like starting on the fringes
which is where it always begins but it's
about setting the stage and the stand
the the setting a precedent and the
precedent here is that if you say things
we don't like you can't do but you can't
bank with us anymore
pushing people to the
you know alienation authorization
pushing people to the outskirts of
society
that's what it's about
the daily wire has this Planned
Parenthood has gone all in on child
gender transition Services which means
you are paying for them the nation's
largest abortion provider offers gender
transition services at hundreds of
clinics across the country and because
planned parenthood's Affiliates get more
than half a billion dollars in
Government funding every year that's
Americans taxpayer dollars at work at
least 344 Planned Parenthood clinics and
41 States across the country currently
offer gender transition Services
according to its website many clinics
offer cross-sex hormones for minors and
well and some provide puberty blockers
while we might not blink at such a
leftist organization dabbling in the
medical transition Market it's a
significant departure from planned
parenthood's core Mission helping kids
move towards sex change is not clearly
related to Family Planning and yet this
is what they're getting into now
so yes Planned Parenthood is doing this
we've we've been talking about how
Planned Parenthood is getting more and
more into this business because and it's
a lot of it's simply Financial they're
losing money
in the in the in the child murder
business they're losing money there
and so now they're getting into the
child mutilation business
but it's also important to note as daily
wire does here that we are paying for it
why are we paying for it
well because Republicans
ran the government
for two years
and didn't do a damn thing about it
didn't even try
didn't even try
they had the White House in Congress for
two years didn't even try to defund
Planned Parenthood can you imagine this
going the other way because it never
would can you imagine if if taxpayers
were giving half a billion dollars a
year to I don't know the NRA
and then and then Democrats won the
White House and majorities in Congress
and they decided to keep sending the
checks
would that ever happen now we would
never send half a billion dollar dollars
a year in tax money to to the NRA in the
first place
but if we work and you could could you
see the Democrats just going along with
it
yeah that would be Unthinkable the first
thing they do the very first thing they
would do is cut off that gravy train
Republicans on the other hand with uh
with them there was barely a discussion
about it
they didn't even think about doing it
no effort was made
and the good thing about defunding the
Planned Parenthood aside from the
obvious
advantages
the other one is that if Democrats are
because you could always say well you
define Planned Parenthood and then and
then Democrats get
comment office and they just reinstate
it
okay even if they do you still cut it
off for however many years
which is a positive good
but also
if the Democrats are going to reinstate
funding
then you force them to reinstate it it's
something they have to actively do and
make the case for it
and actually make the case to the public
here's why we have to give here's this
this business and they kill babies and
they make money killing babies and they
castrate children and make money on that
and you all need to fund them to the
tune of 500 million dollars a year let
them make that case they don't even have
to make the case for it right now
because it in essence Planned Parenthood
is basically on an automatic
subscription renewal system
where the taxpayers don't notice it
and it's never talked about
I can there are many things I can never
forgive the Republican party for this is
one of them
that they they didn't even make it into
a conversation
and what's the excuse there's always
some weak limp wristed excuse about who
owes a filibuster they'd feel about
so get rid of the filibuster and pass it
and at a minimum you try to do it you
make it a conversation you make it a
fight make them make
present their arguments
in favor of taking money from American
families
taking money out of your out of your
chill chicken food out of your
children's mouths and taking that
and giving it to these butchers
Republicans didn't even force them to
make the argument
I just totally Unforgivable
Unforgettable cowardice
all right
what else do we got here
okay here's something a little less
political so the website study finds.org
has this
it says the majority of us wake up
feeling stressed and take an average of
33 minutes before finally feeling human
according to a new survey respondents
agree that brushing their teeth eating
breakfast and Downing a cup of coffee
are an absolute must do within the first
60 Minutes having a hot shower catching
up on the news and making it better also
other actions done first thing in the
morning to get ready for the day who
makes their bed that's the point well my
wife does when I've never understood the
point of it for many however there is no
escaping waking up on the wrong side of
the bed one in six feel stressed the
moment they wake up okay I'm bringing
this up because everybody knows
the reason for this right I mean why why
does it you wait you wake up feeling
stressed you wake up feeling not even
human it was apparently the way it's
being described well it's because
we're all waking up and looking at our
phones right away this is the most toxic
habit imaginable
and uh and most of us are guilty I know
that I am I try to fight it I try not to
do it it's a constant struggle because
for some reason there's an impulse and
then for me especially I have I have
this built-in excuse I can always tell
my Salvage as well this is what I do for
a living I wake up it's even worse than
for me I think because it's like I wake
up and I'm immediately boom I'm working
it's like I've got I've got half a
second in between my eyes opening and
I'm on the phone basically working so um
that's the problem
we we lay down in bed
last thing you do is check your phone
then you wake up first thing you do is
check your phone
uh and it's uh
it's just the worst possible way to
start the day and end it
and I was thinking about this the other
day because I woke up
I checked my phone
and within maybe half a minute maybe a
minute and a half maybe about 90 seconds
so I got on the phone checked it I'm
scrolling through the news or something
so 90 seconds after being conscious
again
I'm reading a story about I think it was
a it was a story about a mass stabbing
in New York I believe
so that's that's the first thing I'm
encountering the first thing I'm in
ingesting and thinking about
is a mass is a stabbing
first thing
worst way to start the day and it's not
just why is it so horrible to start your
day this week like to start your day on
your phone why is that such a bad thing
well it's not just that you're focused
on negativity right off the bat though
that is part of it
it's also that you're waking up
and you're focusing on things that are
far from you right that are that are out
of your control
you haven't gotten dressed yet or
brushed your teeth or said good morning
to your kids and already your mind is
off somewhere else focused on
something out there
right usually something terrible and
dreary and bad
but even if it's not it's still whatever
it's focus on it's still you're away
your mind is away
that's not how it should work instead
there should be a ramp up kind of an
on-ramp sort of where you start with
things that are closest to you your mind
begins its day situated in the present
in the immediate
aware of and engaged with your immediate
surroundings that's how we ought to
start our days that's how we should
actually actually spend the vast
majority of our days too
and and then there will be time to move
your focus elsewhere if you must
but it can't be there right away
right the moment that you wake up
so that's something that we all
we all just need something all right one
other thing I want to mention uh which
is this have have this one on the on
Deck here for a few days it's from the
New York Post it says an opinion from
New York City's eviction court has come
down on the side of polyamorous unions
in the case of a West 49th Street LLC
versus O'Neill New York City Civil Court
Judge Karen May bection
reportedly concluded that polyamorous
relationships are entitled to the same
sort of legal protection given to
two-person relationships
West 49th Street LLC versus O'Neill
involved three individuals Scott
Anderson and Marcus Mark yes O'Neill who
lived together in New York City
apartment and Anderson's husband Robert
Romano who resided elsewhere
Anderson held the lease and following
his death the building's owner argued
that O'Neill had no right to renew the
lease because he has a non-traditional
family member the attorney for the
property owner said that O'Neill's
affidavit in which he claims himself as
a non-traditional member is a fairy tale
according to lgbtq Nation the case
returns to court after further
investigation of the three individuals
relationship interdecision the judge
highlighted the importance of a previous
case and asserted that the existence of
a Triad no matter how they got along
should not automatically dismiss
O'Neill's claim to non-eviction
protections
well
uh whatever the particulars of this case
it's no surprising it's no surprise we
should be surprised by this
and we're gonna see a lot more of this
kind of thing because of course
polyamorous quote unquote unions will
get legal recognition of course they
will
um what what's the argument against them
at this point polygamy polyamory
whatever you want to call it
can make a more compelling argument for
itself and for marital legitimacy
then same-sex unions can I mean there's
historical precedent for polygamy and
most importantly a polygamous Union if
it's between a man and multiple women or
even the other way around which you
never hear about but if it was
um this is this is this is still a union
that can be procreative and as marriage
exists by definition to serve as the
foundation for the Human family
polygamists can make their argument
can kind of stake their claim now it's
not an argument that I agree with by any
means
I would say that polygamy is disordered
it's unhealthy it's morally defective
it's an unstable structure for for kids
a child needs a mom and a dad not four
moms and a dad and or the other way
around
but the point is that if we as a society
have opened up marriage to unions that
cannot participate in its purpose and
function at all
then on what basis do we exclude
polygamy
well we we don't of course there's
there's
the the one argument against it
which is a very good argument
is out the window
um and that's so this is always what it
is always what is meant when we talk
about the slippery slope
okay that's why we said yesterday
uh the conservatives who've been
predicting slippery slope saying we're
on the slippery slope here and there and
and we're always right we've been right
100 of the time
and why is that it's because we're not
actually predicting it the prediction is
not the right way of phrasing it this is
not a a prophecy or a prediction
all we're doing
is we are you know there's there's a
certain thing action whatever
that is being
uh that we we decided we're going to
accept as a society
and then what we are those of us who are
pointing to the slippery slope we are
listening to the arguments that are
being made in favor of this thing
whatever it is
and we're pointing out that well you
know you could take that argument
fully intact
and apply it to all these things over
here that right now we all agree are
unacceptable
and so if that's the case then
either there's something wrong with the
thing you're arguing for right now or
there's something wrong with the
arguments you're presenting for it
but if those are the only arguments
and I can take that argument again fully
intact and I can bring it over here to
these things that that all of us agree
are bad
but that should tell you something
that's all the silver slope does
and that's why we're always right when
we point to it
all right let's get to the comment
section
[Music]
[Music]
the Lemur of Madagascar says the best
part about Matt doing his episodes while
touring is that we get to see him wear
flannels every day again well actually
this these are this is not a flannel and
most of these are not flannels and I'm
wearing these are it's plaid a flannel
is a material
not a not a uh not a pattern so this is
a this is a misconception this is this
is disinformation about flannel
but really the reason that I dress like
this is because it's just too cumbersome
to pack a sports coat and dress shirt
for each episode so this is what you end
up with Colin says I'm 42 and I'm
seriously considered going back to
school to be a doctor I wouldn't be one
until I'm 50 but after hearing this I'm
going to do it I'm undeterred in my aim
yeah please do we need as many sane
normal doctors as we can possibly get so
I'm very happy to hear that
and uh M Houston says Matt I really
needed to hear your words about getting
through Dark Times your matter of fact
and life one wisdom is helping me come
to grips with my own dark times don't
worry no pressure on you because I'm
getting help just wanted to let you know
that there were the reminder that life
is hard at times but worth living really
helps
well I'm glad that it helped you I do
think it's important to be reminded that
that life can be difficult and can
include serious sometimes immense
suffering and I think one of the reasons
why we as a culture are generally so
helpless in the face of suffering and
darkness and so easily overcome by it is
that we don't
we don't really have an understanding of
this inevitable fact of life
that life comes with suffering in
earlier times you know in the past
suffering was such a presence it was
such an inescapable reality that nobody
really needed to be reminded of it and
then when it came along it it uh they
knew that it was going to come they knew
that suffering was part of life and they
dealt with it now it's not to say that
suicide those sorts of things were
unheard of in the past
um of course that it happened
but it wasn't as common as it is now and
especially among young people
the problem then is that the dark times
come
in for modern people the dark time comes
and the person who's suffering it may
Panic emotionally and come to believe
First that it will never end and second
that there must be something irrevocably
broken inside of him or about him that
has made him feel this way because he'll
start to think well wait people aren't
supposed to feel like this this is not
right something's wrong here and that's
what leads to Ultimate Despair and
sometimes suicide I think but if he can
understand that no
you aren't broken okay you aren't
experiencing something unprecedented but
rather you you feel this way because
you're alive
and it is sometimes painful to be alive
and I think people don't want to say
that because it's I I guess it sounds
depressing but it's it's actually not I
think it's hopeful
it's also a reality however you feel
about it it's just true
but if somebody can understand that that
I think um he'll have a better chance of
getting out of it and emerging on the
other end I think of it you know this is
not a Perfect Analogy but
as someone who and I've said many times
admitted
shamefully that I I experience uh
sometimes intense anxiety while flying
even though I fly all the time
and so not a Perfect Analogy but this is
one that comes to mind for me is that
it's it's maybe a bit like turbulence on
an airplane and there are varying
degrees of it you know you can get
really serious turbulence you can get
turbulence it isn't so bad
um but it the turbulence comes from
being in the sky it just comes with
flying it's part of the experience okay
there's no such thing as flying you
couldn't fly for you know you probably
can't make it through even one flight
without a little bit of turbulence in
fact you definitely can't
and if you fly a lot and you fly all the
time then you're going to experience
turbulence all the time it's unpleasant
not gonna like it
but you're not going to panic if you
understand that this is simply part of
flying this just it comes with the
territory
but if you don't realize that if nobody
warns it's your first time flying and no
one even no one ever told you about
turbulence you didn't know that that was
a thing
and then you hit it
now you start to panic because you think
that it was something we're going down
something's wrong here
so it's a little bit like I think the
dark times and the suffering that we
experience internally
um
all right
finally Amanda says the KFC description
is completely accurate I made the
mistake of going through their
drive-through ones
I don't know what was going on but I
gave the guy my card he closed the
window slammed it down on the cash
register and walked off I sat there for
10 minutes before somebody came to the
window to ask me where I what I needed
turns out the guy was the manager and
just walked out mid-order they gave me
back my debit card and a bucket of cold
chicken and yes they did charge me for
the chicken that that is the classic
American
fast food experience especially at KFC
and and it's kind of uh in a way you
know if you want to look on the bright
side of it it's sort of exciting
because when you go to a place like KFC
or Burger King
you just have no idea what you're going
to get you you make your order but the
order is like it's symbolic really at a
place like KMC what you order especially
at the drive-through is it's a symbolic
gesture because it it will not it
there's no re necessarily any reason why
it's going to have any relation to what
is actually given to you
so you go through this whole thing and
it's just a roll of dice and you go get
up to the window you have no idea what
you're actually going to get or if
you're going to be given anything
um you don't know what kind of mood the
person behind the cash register is going
to be in so it's kind of it's exciting
that's how I choose to look at it
back in June of 2020 Candace Owens took
the social media the question the
narrative about George Floyd and took a
barrage of insults as a result
celebrities insulted her GoFundMe de
platformed her as the attacks ramped up
daily wire plus gave her a platform to
speak out without fear of being silenced
and supported her in her investigation
into black lives matter that
organization raised 80 million dollars
through fundraising but no one ever
asked where the money went until now
canazones reveals the truth in her new
documentary the greatest lie ever sold
now streaming exclusively on daily wire
plus because of our members we're able
to create a thriving alternative
platform and pursue the truth wherever
it leads daily wire Plus members
defeated the um vaccine mandates in the
Supreme Court
daily wire Plus members helped us
uncover the Loudoun County sexual
assault cover-up Delaware Plus members
empowered me to expose Vanderbilt's
practices of mutilating children in the
name of gender affirmation care and just
over the weekend daily wire Plus members
caused PayPal to backtrack on its
orwellian fines for misinformation
remember we are speaking for you and
fighting for your values too free speech
is our greatest weapon and with the left
iron grip on our culture and the
mainstream media somebody has to step up
and fill the void if you're not a member
yet go to dailywire.com Walsh to
subscribe and join us today and then of
course make sure to watch Candace
owens's great new documentary the
greatest lie ever sold now available
exclusively on daily wire Plus
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
it may come as a surprise to you
youngsters but there was a time when
Madonna was a pop culture phenomenon she
was a star who produced Sensational
chart-topping Smash Hits now the songs
weren't any good of course they were uh
there was never a time when Madonna was
was making good music but she was
relevant and she sang a lot about sex
and people said wow did you hear that
new Madonna song she sings about sex
again
and music critics said that it was
groundbreaking because music critics
have been calling sexual songs
groundbreaking for the past 55 years or
so
but each generation has its own
revolutionary pop stars who sing about
sex Madonna was replaced by Britney
Spears and then Britney Spears went
insane and shaved her head and she was a
place by Katy Perry and then Katy Perry
finished making her three songs and she
was replaced by somebody else and then
by somebody else and then eventually
cardi B came along and when cardi B came
along music critics were astounded again
they said my God this one sings about
sex in extra raunchy ways this is the
raunchiest we've heard yet it's genius
but then came lizzo and critics
exclaimed wow she sings about sex and
it's raunchy and she's obese and they
were smitten anew the point is that
Madonna's time came and went
she's now 64 years old which translates
to you know 6 400 years old in pop star
years she might as well have been born
in the early days of the Sumerian Empire
at this point and you might think then
that she would simply just uh take her
hundreds of millions of dollars Retreat
to a private island and and live out the
rest of her life in peace confident that
she has passed the whorishness torch to
a new generation of musical prostitutes
but Madonna has thrived on attention
she's lived off of it fed on it like a
vampire bat for decades she doesn't know
how to do anything else
and so Grandma emerges from her Mansion
every once in a while disfigured from
plastic surgery looking strikingly
similar to a 1990s Marilyn Manson
actually and she makes another bid for
the world's attention that's what led to
this Tick Tock video a few days ago
where she seems to come out of the
closet watch
[Music]
she looks like Marilyn Manson she does I
don't mean that as an insult well it's
hard to say that that's not an insult
but anyway so she she throws her panties
towards the garbage can and she misses
and this is her strange metaphorical way
of telling us that she's sexually
attracted to women of course she already
made she already she already kind of
made that announcement when she made out
with Britney Spears on stage at the VMAs
like two decades ago
so this is not exactly breaking news
if she was intending to be in the closet
this whole time and keep it a secret
then she must have been utilizing the
hide in plain sight strategy
but why not go back to the well and and
come out of the closet again this is a
tried and true tactic among celebrities
these days Demi Lovato has come out of
the closet seven different times as
seven different versions of gay and she
she just keeps on doing it everyone
is desperate to come out of the closet
these days even if they were never in
one to begin with
this week we had a national coming out
day which featured lots of uh similar
public declarations like this one from
somebody named Lee sharp he tweets
happy coming out day I am polyamorous
and in an organically formed Triad with
my two lovely Partners we also each in
various amounts date others as well just
as people can love more than one parent
or child or friend romantic love for
multiple people is valid too
well at least the Triad is organically
formed call me a purist but I prefer
organic Triads that's just what I prefer
sometimes I'll buy a few bundles of them
in the produce section at Wegmans keep
them in vases around the house they make
you know for nice decorations especially
because of the of the bright colored
hair now in their case the interesting
thing is that the guy
he looks like a relatively normal guy
like you should be working at Office
Depot or something except for the hair
which looks like it was dyed with food
coloring without his consent while he
was passed out the two women on the
other hand are going for the typical
Star Trek villain aesthetic
but the point is that
though I cannot much relate to the sort
of women that this guy is attracted to
he is still attracted to women he's in a
sexual relationship with women
we're at a point now where straight men
can come out of the closet as straight
men
and nobody questions it as long as their
hair has died in unnatural color
I could color mine green and come out of
the closet as a I could come out of the
closet as a man in a monoamorous
relationship with one woman and as long
as I have the green hair I too would be
welcomed into the LGBT fold
well maybe not me specifically but most
people could do that
the LGBT initialism has been expanded
precisely to include every possible
sexual orientation that's how we end up
with labels like demisexual which
describes people who need to feel an
emotional connection to someone in order
to be sexually attracted to them
otherwise known as just like that's
women that's that's how women are
they're also gray sexuals those are
people who are sometimes sexually
attracted to other people and sometimes
not
so if you've ever been in a room and not
felt sexually attracted to somebody in
it
then you're gray sexual congratulations
you're you're LGBT
and then there are uh there are a
romantic people
which are those who not to be confused
with asexual aromantic those are people
who experience sexual attraction but
often have no romantic feelings or
attachments that go along with it so
they're they're sexual but they're not
they're not romantic
which according to almost any single
woman on the dating scene
describes almost every single man on the
dating scene
the LGBT community is is the only
oppressed victim group in human history
that people are desperate to be
associated with it's the only victim
group that people would pretend they are
a part of for the sake of social status
rather than pretending they're not a
part of for the sake of
self-preservation which is usually
historically how it goes with uh victim
groups it holds this unique position
among historical victim groups because
of course
it is not a victim group at all quite
the contrary it is the group with the
highest cultural status the most social
capital and you always know what that
group is and uh the the saying is like
whatever group you're not allowed to
criticize that's the group with the uh
that's at the at the top of the
hierarchy and that's true with the LGBT
also
but another way of looking at this is
like what what is the group that people
are clamoring to be in what's the club
everybody wants to be a part of
and that partly explains too the extreme
rocket-like rise in gender
non-conforming so-called identities as
the Daily Caller reports this week
Maryland's largest public school
district saw a 582 percent increase in
the number of students identifying as
gender non-conforming in just two years
according to internal data posted to an
Educator's Twitter page Montgomery
Public County Schools
um Montgomery County Public Schools
gathered this data from forms school
counselors fill out when students
approach them to talk about gender
identity issues because the numbers rely
on self-reporting the near Sevenfold
increase from 2019 to 2022 could
indicate a massive increase in the
number of gender diverse students an
environment that encourages those
students to be more open with counselors
or both during the 2019 to 2020 school
year a total of 35 students reported
gender non-conforming to a counselor
including four Elementary School
students 19 middle school students and
12 high schoolers during the 2021-2022
school year the total number of students
reporting gender non-conformity Spike to
239
including 18 Elementary School students
129 middle schoolers and 92 high
schoolers
so kids in school have gotten the
message
how could they not it's screamed at them
everywhere they turn
that being a normal straight person who
identifies as their own biological sex
is uncool and uninteresting
um and so they're trying to keep up with
the trend as kids always have
the difference is that when I was a kid
keeping up with the trend meant wearing
jeans that didn't fit for a brief
strange moment in the 90s it also meant
carrying a yo-yo around in your pocket
and showing off your yo-yo tricks that
was a thing
kids it was a simpler time
now keeping up with the trend means
fundamentally changing your identity
but it is more than just a matter of
trends we're also witnessing I think the
death of personality
people have lost the ability to talk
about their personalities and they're
increasingly losing their ability to
develop Personalities in the first place
LGBT identification and gender
non-conformity are among other things a
replacement for personality
those who claim these identities will
pretend that they're unique and
independent and all of that but in fact
they are fleeing from the unique from
Independence
they seek to label and categorize every
part of themselves with nothing left
over
nothing left of them after they've
claimed all of their letters in the LGBT
alphabet soup
and that's why they all end up looking
the same and sounding the same
and thinking the same way about
everything
it's no wonder that someone like Madonna
has jumped on the trend her life has
been nothing but a series of publicity
stunts
she hasn't had a true human personality
for decades
she doesn't even have a true human face
anymore she has dissolved whatever was
authentic and real within herself and
traded it in for whatever it is that she
is now
but at least she made some money on the
deal
which is more than can be said for most
of the people who are following in her
footsteps
still
I think she is the one who is today
canceled
that'll do it for this portion of the
show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not we'll
talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]